this is one for the whole family we sell
these beautiful bodies and faces and we
here are Kelly song playing you know
actually our Kelly cuz he Peter my
grandma one time he came to our church
into the speech and he just was the
whole front row all right Brandi we use
Brandi Brandi's way better like sweet
Brady back when he first got her titties
like around when Moishe was coming out
okay so we hear the brandy song people
like whooping dancing you know
performing like I look talent show and
then we hear brandy comes out now we
gotta do a wide shot of brandy because
Brandis eyes is where her ears is that
she might be the hammerhead shark of the
R&B world
Brandy's like Emerson funeral home who
wants you to die like a sexy as hell cuz
you might be going to hell Chiron
Emerson funeral home die sexy